is free speech clear to you as a concept
there's been quite a few debates
especially in the digital age
what it means to violate freedom of
speech there's
been a lot of new like novel mechanisms
for people to communicate with each
other like especially on social networks
and it seems that uh unclear
because a lot of times those are managed
by private companies
it's unclear how much protection do the
citizens have to have
when they're communicating a lot of
people are being censored on these
social platforms some people even
presidents get removed from those social
platforms
have you thought about the freedom of
speech in the united states putting in
the world
as it
as it's implemented in the 21st century
given the internet and all those kinds
of things
there is a soviet dissident
named natan sharonsky who
um
survived uh the regime
and he wrote a book
uh in which his thesis was essentially
the way that you can define a free
society is through something called the
town square test can you go to a public
space where you live and criticize your
ruler loudly
without fear of retribution if you can
do that you have free speech i think
that's a pretty good litmus test
most people in this world cannot do that
if you live in havana if you live in
moscow if you live in beijing
you cannot do that and that's not a free
society
in austin texas in boston massachusetts
in london in santiago chile and tokyo
japan in many democracies you can do
that and i think that that's a really
helpful basic sort of litmus test
does the content of the criticism matter
can it be complete lies
meaning
conspiracy theories that involve
claiming that the leader is let's say
a lizard
slash pedophile
slash
you know i'm not saying that those are
lies look into it
but uh they're very unlikely
phenomena so like does that matter i i
think it ends poorly when
the state tries to restrict speech
i think that's kind of how i would
define censorship i think censorship and
de-platforming are two different things
private companies
you know they get to make up their own
rules about what's allowed on their
platforms and i think that's very
different from a government with guns
and an army
restricting the speech of its citizens
with threats of violence these things
are different for me
that violence is a fundamental
difference
i don't know i i um i've gotten a chance
to have dinner with alex jones
and uh i've talked to him a few times
offline and it does i understand why
people are so off put by him
but it does bother me that he's
universally removed from every platform
it feels like there's many more
evil people
bad people
compared to alex jones who still
are given a voice on these platforms
and so i'm uncomfortable with the
universality of the application of the
censorship
by uh
by these platforms but on the flip side
you're right there's not a violence
there's not tanks
there's not guns behind that censorship
yeah it's a bit of a generalization but
alex jones would be in prison or dead if
he
were in north korea or in cuba or in
russia or in china the the authorities
would not tolerate him to do what he did
and here he can kind of do what he wants
he's encountering some resistance in the
marketplace of ideas
large organizations corporations
and a lot of public sentiment
uh in different parts of our country
don't like him and they're doing their
best to drown out his voice but that's
very different from
a violent threat of censorship from the
state and that's what we study that's
what i study are these you know what is
the state doing that's kind of paramount
for for me yeah and that's true because
in the marketplace of ideas there could
be a company that springs up that gives
alex jones a platform and
the united states is not going to
prevent those companies from functioning
of course there's uh from a
technologically tech from a technology
perspective there is uh aws
removing parlor from the platform and
gets a little weird
you know as you get closer and closer to
the computer infrastructure because then
you get closer and closer to the state
actually
the
the more you get to the infrastructure
that's usually managed by the state the
closer it gets to than the control of
the state
i would argue aws is pretty damn close
to infrastructure that's kind of
controlled by the state if you
especially look at other nations
uh china
russia
there's uh i don't know who runs the
computer infrastructure for russia and
china but i bet the state has complete
oversight over that
and so
that level of compute infrastructure
having control
about which social networks can and
cannot operate is very uncomfortable to
me but you're right i think it's it's
good to focus on the obvious violations
of these principles as opposed to the
the gray areas of course the gray areas
are fascinating
you